so Chris Potts is a professor and
actually also the chair of the
Department of linguistics and by
courtesy also at the department of
computer science and he's a great expert
in the area of natural language
understanding so he's you know there
would not be a better person to hear
about a topic than him and we are so
grateful that he could make the time and
he's actually also teaching a graduate
course cs22 for you natural language
understanding that we actually
transformed into a professional course
that is starting next week on the same
topic so you know if you're interested
in learning more we have some links
included uh you know Down Below on your
platform you can check it out and you
know there's so many other things that
can be said about Chris like he has a
super interesting podcast he's running
like so many interesting research papers
like projects he worked on so you know
go ahead and learn more about him like
you should also have a little link I
think without foreign I think we can
kick it off Chris thank you so much once
again
oh thank you so much Petra for the kind
words and uh welcome to everyone it's
wonderful to be here with you all
um I do think that we live in a golden
age for natural language understanding
maybe also a disconcerting age a weird
age but certainly a time of a lot of
innovation and a lot of change uh it's
sort of an interesting moment for
reflection for me because I started
teaching my nlu course at Stanford in
2012 about a decade ago that feels very
recent in my lived experience but it
feels like a completely different age
when it comes to nlu and indeed all of
artificial intelligence I I never would
have guessed in 2012 that we would have
such an amazing array of Technologies
and scientific Innovations and that we
would have these models that were just
so performant and also so widely
deployed in the world this is also a
story of again for better or worse
increasing societal impact and so that
does come together for me into a golden
age and just to reflect on this a little
bit it's really just amazing to think
about how much many of these models you
can get hands on with if you want to
right away right you can download or use
via apis models like Dolly 2 that do
incredible text to image generation
stable diffusion mid-journey they're all
in that class we also have GitHub
co-pilot based in the Codex model for
doing code generation tons of people
derive a lot of value from that system
you.com is at the Leading Edge I would
say of search technologies that are
changing the search experience and also
leading us to new and better results
when we search on the web whisper AI is
an incredible model from openai this
does speech to text and this model
is a generic model that is better than
the best user customized models that we
had 10 years ago just astounding not
something I would have predicted I think
and then of course the star of our show
for today is going to be these big
language models gpt3 is the famous one
you can use it via an API we have all
these open source ones as well that have
come out opt Bloom GPT Neo X these are
models that you can download and work
with to your heart's content provided
that you have all the Computing
resources necessary so just incredible
and I'm sure you're familiar with this
but let's just you know get this into
our Common Ground here it's incredible
what these models can do here's a quick
demo of uh gpt3 I asked the DaVinci 2
engine uh in which year was Stanford
University founded when did it enroll
its first students who is its current
president and what is its mascot and
DaVinci 2 gave a fluent and complete
great answer that is correct on all
counts just incredible that was with
DaVinci 2 we got a big update to that
model in late 2022 that's Da Vinci 3 and
here I'm showing you that it reproduces
that result exactly and I do think that
that DaVinci 3 is a big step forward
over the previous engine
here's actually an example of that you
know I have like to play adversarial
games with this model and so I asked
DaVinci to would it be possible to hire
a team of tamarinds to help me paint my
house assuming I'm willing to pay them
in sufficient quantities of fruit to
meet minimum wage requirements in
California
this is adversarial because I know that
these models don't have a really rich
understanding of the world we live in
they're often distracted by details like
this and sure enough Da Vinci 2 got
confused yes it would be possible to
hire a team of tamarinds to paint your
house you would need to make sure that
you're providing them with enough fruit
to meet minimum wage requirements and so
forth so easily distracted but I tried
this again with DaVinci 3 and with the
same question it gave a very sensible
answer no it would not be possible to
hire a team of tamarins to help you
paint your house DaVinci 2 was not
distracted by my adversarial game this
is not to say that you can't trick Da
Vinci to just go on to Twitter and
you'll find examples of that but again I
do think we're seeing a pretty
remarkable rate of progress toward these
models being robust and relatively
trustworthy
this is also a story of scientific
innovation that was a brief anecdote but
we're seeing this same level of progress
in the tools that we use to measure
system performance in the field I've put
this under the heading of Benchmark
saturate faster than ever this is from a
paper from 2021 that I was involved with
keyla at all here's the framework along
the x-axis I have time going back to the
1990s and along the y-axis I have a
normalized measure of our estimate of
human performance that's the red line
set at zero so mnist digit recognition a
grand old data set in the field that was
launched in the 1990s and it took about
20 years for us to surpass this estimate
of human performance
switchboard is a similar story launched
in the 90s this is the speech to text
problem it took about 20 years for us to
get up past this red line here
imagenet is newer this was launched in
2009 it took about 10 years for us to
reach this saturation point
and from here the pace is really going
to pick up so Squad 1.1 is question
answering that was solved in about three
years
the response was Squad 2.0 that was
solved in less than two years
and then the glue Benchmark if you were
in the field you might recall back the
glue Benchmark is this big set of tasks
that was meant to stress test our best
models when it was announced a lot of us
worried that it was just too hard for
present-day models but glue was
saturated in less than a year the
response was super glue meant to be much
harder it was also saturated in less
than a year a remarkable story of
progress undoubtedly even if you're
cynical about this measure of human
performance we are still seeing a rapid
increase in the rate of change here and
you know 2021 was ages ago in the story
of AI now I think this same thing
carries over into the current ERA with
our largest language models this is from
a really nice post from Jason way he is
assessing emergent abilities in large
language models you see eight of them
given here along the x-axis for these
plots you have model size and on the
y-axis you have accuracy and what Jason
is showing is that at a certain Point
these really big models just attain
these abilities to do these really hard
tasks and Jason estimates that for 137
tasks models are showing this kind of
emergent ability and that includes tasks
that were explicitly set up to help us
stress test our largest language model
they're just following away one by one
really incredible
now we're going to talk a little bit
later about the factors that are driving
this enormous progress for large
language models but I want to be up
front that one of the major factors here
is just the raw size of these models you
can see that in Jason's plots that's
where the emergent ability kicks in and
let me put that in context for you so
this is from a famous platform of paper
that's actually about making models
smaller and what they did is track the
rise of you know increases in model size
along the x-axis we have time depth it
only goes back to 2018. it's not very
long ago and in 2018 the largest of our
models had around 100 million parameters
seems small by current comparisons
in late 19 in late 2019 early 2020 we
start to see a rapid increase in the
size of these models so that by 20 at
the end of 2020 we have this Megatron
model at 8.3 billion parameters I
remember when that came out it seemed
like it must be some kind of typo I
could not fathom that we had a model
that was that large but now of course
this is kind of on the small side soon
after that we got an 11 billion
parameter variant of that model and then
gpd3 came out that says 175 billion
parameters and that one too now looks
small in comparison to these truly
gargantuan Megatron models and the Palm
model from Google which surpassed 500
billion parameters
I want to emphasize that this has made a
complete mockery of the y-axis of this
plot to capture the scale correctly we
would need 5 000 of these slides stacked
on top of each other again it still
feels weird to say that but that is the
truth the scale of this is absolutely
enormous and not something I think that
I would have anticipated way back when
we were dealing with those hundred
million parameter babies by comparison
they seem large to me at that point
so this brings us to our central
question it's a golden age this is all
undoubtedly exciting and the things that
I've just described to you are going to
have an impact on your lives positive
and negative but certainly an impact
but I take it that we are here today
because we are researchers and we would
like to participate in this research and
that could leave you with a kind of
worried feeling how can you contribute
to nlu in this era of these gargantuan
models I've set this up as a kind of
flow chart first question do you have 50
million dollars and a love of deep
learning infrastructure
if the answer is yes to this question
then I would encourage you to go off and
build your own large language model you
could change the world in this way I
would also request that you get in touch
with me maybe you could join my research
group and maybe fund my research group
that would be wonderful
but I'm assuming that most of you cannot
truthfully answer yes to this question
I'm in the no Camp right and on both
counts I am both dramatically short of
the funds and I also don't have a love
of deep learning infrastructure so for
those of us who have to answer no to
this question how can you contribute
even if the answer is no there are tons
of things that you can be doing all
right so just topics that are front of
mind to me include retrieval augmented
in context learning this could be small
models that are performant
you could always contribute to creating
better benchmarks this is a perennial
challenge for the field and maybe the
most significant thing that you can do
is just create devices that allow us to
accurately measure the performance of
our systems
you could also help us solve what I've
called The Last Mile problem for
productive applications these Central
developments in AI take us 95 percent of
the way toward utility but that last
five percent actually having a positive
impact on people's lives often requires
twice as much development twice as much
Innovation across domain experts people
who are good at human computer
interaction and AI experts right and
there's so there's just a huge amount
that has to be done to realize the
potential of these Technologies
and then finally you could think about
achieving faithful human interpretable
explanations of how these models behave
if we're going to trust them we need to
understand how they work at a human
level that is supremely challenging and
therefore this is incredibly important
work you could be doing
now I would love to talk with you about
all four of those things and really
elaborate on them but our time is short
and so what I've done is select one
topic retrieval augmented in context
learning to focus on because it's it's
intimately connected to this notion of
in-context learning and it's a place
where all of us can participate in lots
of innovative ways so that's kind of the
central plan for the day before I do
that though I just want to help us get
more common ground around what I take to
be the really Central change that's
happening as a result of these large
language models and I've put that under
the heading of the rise of in-context
learning
again this is something we're all
getting used to it really remarks a
genuine paradigm shift I would say
in context learning really traces to the
gpt3 paper there are precedents earlier
in the literature but it was the gpt3
paper that really gave it a thorough
initial investigation and showed that it
had promised with the earliest GPT
models here's how this works we have our
big language model and we prompt it with
a bunch of text so for example this is
from that gpt3 paper we might prompt the
model with a context passage and a title
we might follow that with one or more
demonstrations here the demonstration is
a question and an answer and the goal of
the demonstration is to help the model
learn in context that is from The Prompt
we've given it what Behavior we're
trying to elicit from and so here you
might say we're trying to coax the model
to do extractive question answering to
find the answer as a substring of the
passage we gave it you might have a few
of those and then finally we have the
actual question we want the model to
answer we prompt the model with this
prompt here that puts it in some State
and then its generation is taken to be
the prediction or response and that's
how we assess its success
and the whole idea is that the model can
learn in context that is from this
prompt what we want it to do
so that gives you a sense for how this
works you've probably all prompted
language models like you like this
yourself already I want to dwell on this
for a second though this is a really
different thing from what we used to do
throughout artificial intelligence let
me contrast in context learning with the
standard Paradigm of standard
supervision
back in the old days of 2017 or whatever
we would typically set things up like
this we would have say we wanted to
solve a problem like classifying texts
according to whether they express
nervous anticipation a complex human
emotion the first step would be that we
would need to create a data set of
positive and negative examples of that
phenomenon and then we would train a
custom built model to make the binary
distinction reflected in the labels here
it can be surprisingly powerful but you
can start to see already how this isn't
going to scale to the complexity of The
Human Experience we're going to need
separate data sets and maybe separate
models for optimism and sadness and
every other emotion you can think of and
that's just a subset of all the problems
we might want our models to solve for
each one we're going to need data and
maybe a custom built model
the promise of in-context learning is
that a single big frozen language model
can serve all those goals and in this
mode we do that prompting thing that I
just described we're going to give the
model examples just expressed in flat
text of positive and negative instances
and hope that that's enough for it to
learn in context about the distinction
we're trying to establish this is really
really different consider that over here
the phrase nervous anticipation has no
special status the model doesn't really
process it it's entirely structured to
make a binary distinction and the label
nervous anticipation is kind of for us
on the right the model needs to learn
essentially the meanings of all of these
terms and our intentions and figure out
how to make these distinctions on new
examples all from a prompt
it's just weird and wild that this works
at all I think I used to be discouraging
about this as an Avenue and now we're
seeing it bear so much fruit
what are the mechanisms behind this I'm
going to identify a few of them for you
the first one is certainly the
Transformer architecture this is the
basic building block of essentially all
the language models that I've mentioned
so far we have great coverage of the
Transformer in our course natural
language understanding so I'm going to
do this quickly the Transformer starts
with word embeddings and positional
encodings on top of those we have a
bunch of attention mechanisms these give
the name to the famous paper attention
is all you need which announce the
Transformer evidently attention is not
all you need because we have these
positional encodings at the bottom and
then we have a bunch of feed forward
layers and regularization steps at the
top
but attention really is the Beating
Heart of this model and it really was a
dramatic departure from the fancy
mechanisms lstms and so forth that were
characteristic of the pre-transformer
era
so that's essentially though on the
diagram here the full model in the
course we have a bunch of materials that
help you get Hands-On with Transformer
representations and also dive deep into
meth into the mathematics so I'm just
going to skip past this I will say that
if you dive deep you're likely to go
through the same Journey we all go
through where your first question is how
on Earth does this work this diagram
looks very complicated
but then you come to terms with it and
you realize oh this is actually a bunch
of very simple mechanisms
but then you arrive at a question that
is a burning question for all of us why
does this work so well this remains an
open question a lot of people are
working on explaining why this is so
effective and that is certainly an area
in which all of us could participate
analytic work understanding why this is
so successful
the second big innovation here is a
realization that what I've called
self-supervision is an incredibly
powerful mechanism for acquiring Rich
representations of form and meaning this
is also very strange in self-supervision
the model's only objective is to learn
from co-occurrence patterns in the
sequences it's trained on this is purely
distributional learning another way to
put this is the model is just learning
to assign high probability to attested
sequences
that is the fundamental mechanism we
think about these models as generators
but generation is just sampling from the
model that's a kind of secondary or
derivative process the main thing is
learning from these co-occurrence
patterns an enlightening thing about the
current ERA is that it's fruitful for
these sequences content to contain lots
of symbols not just language but
computer code sensor readings even
images and so forth those are all just
symbol streams and the model learns
associations among them
the core thing about self-supervision
though that really contrasts it with the
standard supervised Paradigm I mentioned
before is that the objective doesn't
mention any specific specific symbols or
relations between them is entirely about
learning these co-occurrence patterns
and from this simple mechanism we get
such Rich results
and that is incredibly empowering
because you need hardly any human effort
to train a model with self-supervision
you just need vast quantities of these
symbol streams and so that has
facilitated the rise of another
important mechanism here large-scale
pre-training and there are actually two
innovations that are happening here
right so we see the rise of large
pre-scale pre-training in the earliest
work on static word representations like
word to VEC and glove
and what those teams realize is not only
that it's powerful to train on vast
quantities of data using just
self-supervision but also that it's
empowering to the community to release
those parameters not just data not just
code but the actual learned
representations for other people to
build on that has been incredible in
terms of building effective systems
after those we get Elmo which was the
first Model to do this for contextual
word representations truly large
language models then we get Bert of
course and GPT and then finally of
course gpt3 at a scale that was really
previously unimagined and maybe kind of
unimaginable for me
a final piece that we should not
Overlook is the role of human feedback
in all of this and I'm thinking in
particular of the open AI models I've
given a lot of coverage so far of this
mechanism of self-supervision but we
have to acknowledge that our best models
are what openai calls the instruct
models and those are trained with way
more than just self-supervision
this is a diagram from the chat GPT blog
post it has a lot of details I'm
confident that there are really two
pieces that are important first the
language model is fine-tuned on human
level supervision just making binary
distinctions about good generations and
bad ones that's already Beyond
self-supervision and then in a second
phase the model generates outputs and
humans rank all of the outputs the model
has produced and that feedback goes into
a lightweight reinforcement learning
mechanism in both of those phases we
have important human contributions that
take us beyond that self-supervision
step and kind of reduce the magical
feeling of how these models are
achieving so much
I'm emphasizing this because I think
what we're seeing is a return to a
familiar and kind of cynical sounding
story about AI which is that many of the
transformative step forwards are
actually on the back of a lot of human
effort behind the scenes expressed at
the level of training data
but on the positive side here it is
incredible that this human feedback is
having such an important impact instruct
models are best in class in the field
and we have a lot of evidence that that
must be because of these human feedback
steps happening at a scale that I assume
is astounding they must have at open AI
large teams of people providing very
fine-grained feedback across lots of
different domains with lots of different
tasks in mind
final piece by way of background
prompting itself this has been a real
journey for all of us I've described
this as step by step and Chain of
Thought reasoning
to give you a feel for how this is
happening let's just imagine that we've
posed a question like can our models
reason about negation that is if we
didn't eat any food does the model know
that we didn't eat any pizza
in the old days of 2021 we were so naive
we would prompt models with just that
direct question like is it true that if
we didn't need any food then we didn't
eat any pizza and we would see what the
model said in Return
now in 2023 we know so much and we have
learned that it can really help to
design a prompt that helps the model
reason in the intended ways this is
often called step-by-step reasoning
here's an example of a prompt that was
given to be by Omar khatab you start by
telling it it's a logic and Common Sense
reasoning exam for some reason that's
helpful then you give it some specific
instructions and then you use some
special markup to give it an example of
the kind of reasoning that you would
like it to follow
after that example comes the actual
prompt and in this context what we
essentially ask the model to do is
express its own reasoning and then
conditional on what it has produced
create an answer
and the eye-opening thing about the
current ERA is that this can be
transformatively better I think if you
wanted to put this poetically you'd say
that these large language models are
kind of like alien creatures and it's
taking us some time to figure out how to
communicate with them and together with
all that instruct fine-tuning with human
supervision we're converging on prompts
like this as the powerful device and
this is exciting to me because what's
really emerging is that this is a kind
of very light way of programming an AI
system using only prompts as opposed to
all the Deep learning code that we used
to have to write and that's going to be
incredibly empowering in terms of system
development and experimentation
all right so we have our background in
place I'd like to move to my main topic
here which is retrieval augmented in
context learning what you're going to
see here is a combination of language
models with retriever models which are
themselves under the hood large language
models as well
let me start with a bit of the back
story here I think we're all probably
vaguely aware at this point that large
language models have been
revolutionizing search again the star of
this is the Transformer or maybe more
specifically its famous spokes model
Bert right after Bert was announced
around 2018 Google announced that it was
incorporating aspects of Bert into its
core search technology and Microsoft
made a similar announcement at about the
same time and I think those are just two
public-facing stories of you know many
instances of large search Technologies
having burnt Elements Incorporated into
them in that era and then of course in
the current ERA we have startups like
you.com which have made large language
models pretty Central to the entire
search experience in the form of you
know delivering results but also
interactive search with conversational
agents so that's all exciting but
I am an NLP or at heart and so for me in
a way the more exciting Direction here
is the fact that finally search is
revolutionizing NLP by and helping us
bridge the gap into much more relevant
knowledge intensive tasks to give you a
feel for how that's happening let's just
use question answering as an example so
prior to this work in NLP we would post
question answer in your QA in the
following way
you saw this already with the gpt3
example we would have as given at test
time a title and a context passage and
then a question
and the task of the model is to find the
answer to that question as a literal
substring of the context passage which
was guaranteed by the nature of the data
set
as you can imagine models are really
good at this task superhuman certainly
at this task but it's also a very
rarified task this is not a natural form
of question answering in the world and
it's certainly unlike the scenario of
for example doing web search
so the promise of the open formulations
of this task are that we're going to
connect more directly with the real
world at in this formulation at test
time we're just given a question
and the standard strategy is to rely on
some kind of retrieval mechanism to find
relevant evidence in a large Corpus or
maybe even the web and then we proceed
as before
this is a much harder problem because
we're not going to get the substring
guarantee anymore because we're
dependent on the retriever to find
relevant evidence but of course it's a
much more important task because this is
much more like our experience of
searching on the web
now I've kind of biased already in
describing things this way where I
assume we're retrieving a passage but
there is another narrative out there let
me skip to this then you could call this
like the llms for everything approach
and this would be where there's no
explicit retriever you just have a
question come in you have a big opaque
model process that question and out
comes an answer voila you hope that the
user's information need is met directly
no separate retrieval mechanism just the
language model doing everything I think
this is an incredibly inspiring vision
but we should be aware that there are
lots of kind of danger zones here so the
first is just efficiency one of the
major factors driving that explosion in
model size that I tracked before is that
in this llms for everything approach we
are asking this model to play the role
of both knowledge store and language
capability if we could separate those
out we might get away with smaller
models
we have a related problem of
updateability suppose a fact in the
world changes a document on the web
changes for example
well you're going to have to update the
parameters of this big opaque model
somehow to conform to the change in
reality
there are people hard at work on that
problem that's a very exciting problem
but I think we're a long way from being
able to offer guarantees that a change
in the world is reflected in the Model
Behavior and that plays into all sorts
of issues of trustworthiness and
explainability of behavior and so forth
also we have an issue of Providence look
at the answer at the bottom there is
that the correct answer should you trust
this model right in the standard web
search experience we typically are given
some web pages that we can click on to
verify at least at the next level of
detail whether the information is
correct but here we're just given this
response and if the model also generated
a provenance string if it told us where
it found the information we'd be left
with the concern that that provenance
string was also untrustworthy right and
this is like a really breaking a
fundamental contract that users expect
to have with search Technologies I
believe
so those are some things to worry about
there are positives though of course
these models are incredibly effective at
meeting your information need directly
and they're also outstanding at
synthesizing information if your
question can only be answered by 10
different web pages it's very likely
that the language model will still be
able to do it without you having to hunt
through all those pages
so exciting but lots of concerns here
here is the alternative of retrieval
augmented approaches right oh I can't
resist this actually
just to give you an example of how
important this trustworthy thing can be
so
um I used to be impressed by DaVinci 3
because it would give a correct answer
to the question are professional
baseball players allowed to glue small
Wings onto their caps this is a question
that I got from a wonderful article by
Hector Levesque where he encourages us
to stress test our models by asking them
questions that would seem to run up
against any simple distributional or
statistical learning model and really
get it whether they have a model of the
world
and for Da Vinci 2 it gave what it
looked like a really good levec style
answer there is no rule against it but
it is not common that seems true
so I was disappointed I guess or I'm
actually not sure how to feel about this
one I asked DaVinci 3 the same question
and it said no professional baseball
players are not allowed to glue small
Wings onto their caps Major League
Baseball has strict rules about the
appearance of players uniforms and caps
in any modifications of the Caps are not
allowed
that also sounds reasonable to me is it
true it would help enormously if the
model could offer me at least a web page
with with evidence that's relevant to
these claims otherwise I'm simply left
wondering and I think that shows you
that we've kind of broken this implicit
contract with the user that we expect
from search
so that'll bring me to my alternative
here retrieval based or retrieval
augmented NLP to give you a sense for
this at the top here I have a standard
search box and I've put in a very
complicated question indeed
the first step in this approach is
familiar from the llms for everything
one we're going to encode that query
into a dense numerical representation
capturing aspects of its form and
meaning we use a language model for that
the next step is new though we are also
going to use a language model maybe the
same one we use for the query to process
all of the documents in our document
collection
so each one has some kind of numerical
deep learning representation now on the
basis of these representations we can
now score documents with respect to
queries just like we would in the
standard good old days of information
retrieval so we can reproduce every
aspect of that familiar experience if we
want to we're just doing it now in this
very rich semantic space
so we get some results back and we could
offer those to the user as ranked
results but we can also go further we
could have another language model call
it a reader or a generator slurp up
those retrieve passages and synthesize
them into a single answer maybe meeting
the user's information need directly
right so let's check in on how we're
doing with respect to our goals here
first efficiency I won't have time to
substantiate this today but these
systems in terms of parameter counts can
be much smaller than the integrated
approach I mentioned before
we also have an easy path to
updateability we have this index here so
as Pages change in our document store we
simply use our Frozen language model to
reprocess and re-represent them and we
can have a pretty good guarantee at this
point that information changes will be
reflected in the retrieved results down
here
we're also naturally tracking Providence
because we have all these documents and
they're used to deliver the results and
we can have that carry through into the
generation so we've kept that contract
with the user
these models are incredibly effective
across lots of literature we're seeing
that retrieval augmented approaches are
just superior to the fully integrated
llms for everything one
and we've retained the benefit of llms
for everything because we have this
model down here the reader generator
that can synthesize information into
answers that meet the information need
directly
so that's my fundamental pitch now again
things are changing fast and even the
approach to designing these systems is
also changing really fast so in the in
the previous era of 2020
we would have these pre-trained
components like we have our index and
our retriever maybe we have a language
model like reader generator and you
might have other pre-trained components
image processing and so forth so you
have all these assets and the question
is how are you going to bring them
together into an integrated solution
the standard deep learning answer to
that question is to define a bunch of
task specific parameters that are meant
to tie together all those components and
then you learn those parameters with
respect to some task and you hope that
that has kind of created an effective
integrated system
that's the modular vision of deep
learning the truth in practice is that
even for very experienced researchers
and system designers this can often go
really wrong and debugging these systems
and figure out how figuring out how to
improve them can be very difficult
because they are so opaque and the scale
is so large
but maybe we're moving out of an era in
which we have to do this at all
so this will bring us back to in-context
learning the fundamental Insight here is
that many of these models can in
principle communicate in natural
language right so a retriever
is abstractly just a device for pulling
in text and producing text with scores
and a language model is also a device
for pulling in text and producing text
with scores
and we have already seen in my basic
picture of retrieval augmented
approaches that we could have the
retriever communicate with the language
model via retrieve results
well what if we just allow that to go in
both directions now we've got a system
that is essentially constructed by
prompts that help these models do
message passing between them in
potentially very complicated ways an
entirely new approach to system design
that I think is going to have an
incredible democratizing effect on who
designs these systems and what they're
for
let me give you a deep sense for just
how wide open the design space is here
again to give you a sense for how much
of this research is still left to be
done even in this Golden Era
let's imagine a search context the
question is what course to take
what we're going to do in this new mode
is begin a prompt that contains that
question just as before
and now what we can do next is retrieve
a context passage that'll be like the
retrieval augmented approach that I
showed you at the start of this section
right you could just use our retriever
for that but there's more that could be
done what about demonstrations let's
imagine that we have a little train set
of QA pairs that kind of demonstrate for
our system what the intended behavior is
well we can add those into the prompt
and now we're giving the system a lot of
few shot guidance about how to learn in
context right
but that's also just the beginning I
might have sampled these training
examples randomly from my train set but
I have a retriever remember and so what
I could do instead is find the
demonstrations that are the most similar
to the user's question and put those in
my prompt with the expectation that that
will help it understand kind of topical
coherence and lead to better results
but I could go further right I could use
my retriever again to find relevant
context passages for each one of those
demonstrations to further help it figure
out how to reason in terms of evidence
and that also opens up a huge design
space we could do what we call hindsight
retrieval where for each one of these
we're using both the question and the
answer to find relevant context passages
to really give you integrated
informational packets that the model can
benefit from
and there's lots more that we could do
with these demonstrations you're
probably starting to see it right we
could do some rewriting and so forth
really make sophisticated use of the
Retriever and the language model
interwoven
we could also think about how we
selected this background passage I was
assuming that we would uh just retrieve
the most relevant passage according to
our question
but we could also think about rewriting
the user's query in terms of the
demonstrations that we could constructed
to get a new query that will help the
model that's especially powerful if you
have a kind of interactional mode where
the demonstrations are actually part of
like a dialogue history or something
like that
and then finally we could turn our
attention to how we're actually
generating the answer I was assuming we
would take the top generation from the
language model but we could do much more
we could filter its generations to just
those that match a substring of the
passage reproducing some of the old mode
of question answering but now in this
completely open formulation that can be
incredibly powerful if you know your
model can retrieve good background
passages here
those are two simple steps you could
also go all the way to the Other Extreme
and use the full retrieval augmented
generation or rag model which is that
essentially creates a full probability
model that allows us to marginalize out
the contribution of passages that can be
incredibly powerful in terms of making
maximal use of the capacity of this
model to generate text conditional on
all the work that we did up here
I hope that's given you a sense for just
how much can happen here what we're
starting to see I think is that there is
a new programming mode emerging it's a
programming mode that involves using
these large pre-trained components to
design in code
prompts that are essentially full AI
systems that are entirely about message
passing between these Frozen components
we have a new paper out that's called
demonstrate search predict or DSP this
is a lightweight programming framework
for doing exactly what I was just
describing for you
and one thing I want to call out is that
our results are fantastic
now you know we can Pat ourselves on the
back we have a very talented team and so
it's no surprise the results are so good
but I actually want to be upfront with
you I think the real insight here is
that it is such early days in terms of
us figuring out how to construct these
prompts how to program these systems
that we've only just begun to understand
what's optimal we have explored only a
tiny part of the space and everything
we're doing is sub-optimal and that's
just the kind of conditions where you
get these huge leap forwards leaps
forward in performance on these tasks so
I suspect that the Bold row that we have
here will not be long lived given how
much Innovation is happening in this
space
and I want to make a pitch for our
course here right so we have in this
course a bunch of assignment slash bake
offs uh and the way that works
essentially is that you have an
assignment that helps you build some
baselines and then work toward an
original system which you enter into a
bake off which is a kind of informal
competition around data and modeling
our newest of these is called few shot
open QA with Colbert retrieval it's a
version of the problems that I've just
been describing for you this is a
problem that could not even have been
meaningfully posed five years ago and
now we are seeing students doing
incredible Cutting Edge things in this
mode it's exactly what I was just
describing for you and we're in the sort
of moment where a student project could
lead to a paper that you know really
leads to state-of-the-art Performance in
surprising ways again because there is
just so much research that has to be
done here
I'm running out of time what I think
I'll do is just briefly call out again
those important other areas that I've
given short trip to today but I think
are just so important starting with data
sets I've been talking about system
design and task performance but it is
now and will always be the case that
contributing new Benchmark data sets is
basically the most important thing you
can do I like this analogy Jacques
Cousteau said Water and Air the two
essential fluids on which all life
depends I would extend that to NLP uh
our data sets are the resource on which
all progress depends now Cousteau
extended this with have become Global
garbage cans I am not that cynical about
our data sets I think we've learned a
lot about how to create effective data
sets we're getting better at this but we
need to watch out for this metaphorical
pollution and we need always to be
pushing our systems with harder tasks
that come closer to the human
capabilities that we're actually
actually trying to get them to achieve
and without contributions of data sets
we could be tricking ourselves when we
think we're making a lot of progress
the second thing that I wanted to call
out relates to model explainability you
know we're in an era of incredible
impact and that has rightly turned
researchers to questions of system
reliability safety trust approved use
and pernicious social biases we have to
get serious about all these issues if
we're going to responsibly have all of
the impact that we're achieving at this
point
all of these things are incredibly
difficult because the systems we're
talking about are these enormous opaque
impossible to understand analytically
devices like this that are just clouding
our understanding of them and so to me
that shines a light on the importance of
achieving analytic guarantees about our
model behaviors that seems to me to be a
prerequisite for getting serious about
any one of these topics and the goal
there in our terms is to achieve
faithful human interpretable
explanations of Model Behavior we have
great coverage of these methods in the
course Hands-On materials screencasts
and other things that will help you
participate in this research and also as
a side effect right absolutely
outstanding discussion and Analysis
sections for your papers
and the final thing I wanted to call out
is just that last mile problem
fundamental advances in AI take us 95
percent of the way there but that last
five percent is every bit as difficult
as the first 95. in my group we've been
looking a lot at image accessibility
this is an incredibly important societal
problem because images are so Central to
Modern Life across the being on the web
and in social media also in the news and
our scientific discourse and it's a sad
fact about the current state of the
world that almost none of these images
are made non-visually accessible so
blind and low vision users are basically
unable to understand all this context
and receive all of this information
something has to change that
image based text generation has become
incredibly good over the last 10 years
that's another story of astounding
progress but it has yet to take us to
the point where we can actually write
useful descriptions of these images that
would help a BLB user and that last bit
is going to require HCI research
linguistic research and fundamental
advances in Ai and by the way lots of
astounding new data sets and this is
just one example of in the innumerable
number of Applied problems that fall
into this mode and that can be very
exciting for people who have domain
expertise that can help us close that
final mile
so let me wrap up here
um I don't want to have a standard
conclusion I think it's fun to close
with some predictions about the future
and I have put this under the heading of
predictions for the text next 10 years
or so although I'm about to retract that
for reasons I will get to but here are
the predictions
first laggard industries that are rich
in Text data will be transformed in part
by NLP technology and that's likely to
happen from some disruptive newcomers
coming out of left field
second prediction artificial assistance
will get dramatically better and become
more ubiquitous with the side effect
that you'll often be unsure in life
whether this customer service
representative is a person or an AI or
some team combining the two
many kinds of writing including student
papers at universities will be done with
AI writing assistance and this might be
transparently true given how
sophisticated auto-complete and other
tools have gotten at this point
and then finally the negative effects of
NLP and of AI will be Amplified along
with the positives I'm thinking of
things like disinformation spread Market
disruption systemic bias
it's almost sure to be the case if it
hasn't already happened already that
there will be some calamitous world
event that traces to the intentional or
unintentional misuse of some AI
technology that's in our future
so I think these are reasonable
predictions and I'm curious for yours
but I have to tell you that I made these
predictions in 2020 two years ago
with the expectation that they would be
good for 10 years
but more than half of them probably have
already come true two and three are
definitely true about the world we live
in and on the flip side I just failed to
predict so many important things like
the most prominent example is that I
just failed to predict the progress we
would see in text image models like
Dolly 2 and and stable diffusion in fact
I'll be honest with you I might have bet
against them I thought that was an area
that was going to languish for a long
time and yet nonetheless seemingly out
of nowhere we had this incredible set of
advances and there are probably lots of
other areas where I would make similarly
bad traditions
um so I said 10 years but I think my new
rule is going to be that I'm going to
predict only through 2024 at the very
outside because
in 10 years the only thing I can say
with confidence is that we'll we will be
in a radically different place from
where we are now but what that place
will be like is anyone's guess I'm
interested in your predictions about it
but I think I will stop here
thank you very much
thank you so much Chris for the engaging
and extremely interesting topic and
presentation that you have given I'm
always so amazed by all the new things
you're mentioning every single time we
talk I feel it is something new
something exciting you know it's not you
not me especially not me like expected
that you'll be talking about it so soon
many questions came in I must already
say we will unfortunately not be able to
get to all of them because the time is
limited and the audience is so active
and so many people showed up so let me
pick a few
um Chris so the cost of the training
model so it seems it really scales with
the size and we are paying a lot of
attention and like putting a lot of
effort into the training uh so what does
it mean for the energy requirements and
I guess you are talking about
predictions but like how does it look
like now and like what do you recommend
people to to pay attention to
oh it's a wonderful set of questions to
be answering and critically important I
mean
um I ask myself you know you know if you
think about Industries in the world some
of them are improving in terms of their
environmental impacts some are getting
much worse where is artificial
intelligence in that is it getting
better or is it getting worse I don't
know the answer because on the one hand
the expenditure for training and now
serving for example gpt3 to everyone who
wants to use it is absolutely enormous
and has real costs like measured in
emissions and things like that on the
other hand
this is a centralization of all of that
and that can often bring real benefits
and I I want to not forget of the
previous era where every single person
trained every single model from scratch
and so now a lot of our research is
actually just using these Frozen
components they were expensive but the
expenditure of our lab is probably going
way down because we are not training
these big models
it kind of reminds me of that last mile
problem again in the previous era it was
like we were all driving to pick up our
groceries everywhere huge expenditure
with all those individual trips now it's
much more like they're all brought to
the end of the street and we walk to get
them
but of course that's done in big trucks
and those have real consequences as well
I don't know but I hope that a lot of
smart people work continue to work on
this problem and that'll lead to
benefits in terms of us doing all these
things more efficiently as well
thank you so much
um the next question and you touched on
that a few times but it might be good to
summarize that a little bit uh because
we got a lot of the questions about kind
of the trustworthiness and if the model
actually knows that it's wrong or
correct and like how do how do we trust
the model or like how do we achieve the
trustworthiness of the model because
right now it's a lot of the generation
happening generative models happening so
like how do we pass that
it's a an incredibly good question and
it is the thing I have in mind when
we're doing all our work on explaining
models
because I feel like offering faithful
human interpretable explanations is the
step we can take toward trustworthiness
it's a very difficult problem I just
want to add that um
it might be even harder than we've
anticipated because people are also
pretty untrustworthy
it's just that individual people often
don't have like a systemic effect right
so if you're really doing a poor job at
something you probably impact just a
handful of people and other people say
at your company do a much better job but
these AIS are now it's like they're
everyone and so any kind of small
problem that they have is Amplified
across the entire population they
interact with and that's going to
probably mean that our standards for
trustworthiness for them need to be
higher than they are for humans and
that's another sense in which they're
going to have to be superhuman to
achieve the jobs we're asking of them
and the field cannot offer guarantees
right now
so come help us
fascinating thank you so much and like I
saw also some questions or comments
about the bias in data and like you
mentioned it also right like like we are
improving like there is a big
Improvement happening
um
last question for you
um like a little bit of a thought
experiment but like do you think that
the large language models might be able
to come up with answers to as yet
unanswered important scientific
questions like something we are not even
sure that it even exists like in our
minds right now oh it's a wonderful
question yet and people are asking this
across multiple domains like they're
producing incredible artwork but are we
now trapped inside a feedback loop
that's going to lead to less truly
Innovative art and and if we ask them to
generate text are they going to do
either weird irrelevant stuff or just
more of the boring average case stuff
um
I don't know the answer I will say
though that these models have an
incredible capacity to synthesize
information across sources
and I feel like that is a source of
innovation for humans as well simply
making those connections and it might be
true that there is nothing new Under the
Sun but there are lots of new
connections perspectives and so forth to
be had
and I actually do have faith that models
are going to be able to at least
simulate some of that and it might look
to us like innovation
but this is not to say that this is uh
not a concern for us it should be
something we think about especially
because we might be heading into an era
when whether we want them to or not
mostly these models are trained on their
own output which is being put on the web
and then consumed when people create
train sets and so forth and so on
great thank you so much and we are
nearing the end so like last Point
um do you have any like last remarks any
anything anything interesting you would
suggest others to look at follow read
um learn about to kind of get more
acquainted with the subject like learn
more about the nlu gpt3 other large
language models any recommendations
the thing that comes to mind based on
all the interactions I have with the
professional development students who've
taken our course before is that a lot of
you I'm guessing have incredibly value
valuable domain expertise you work in an
industry in a position that he has
taught you tons of things and giving you
lots of skills and my Last Mile problem
shows you that that is relevant to Ai
and therefore you could bring it to bear
on AI and we might all benefit where you
would be taking all these Innovations
you can learn about in our course and
other courses combining that with your
domain expertise and maybe actually
making progress in a meaningful way on a
problem
as opposed to merely having demos and
things that our scientific Community
often produces real impact
so often requires real domain expertise
of the sort you all have
beginning of the quarter hectic Stanford
live I'd really appreciate you taking
the time to to do this to run this
webinar thank you also everyone
everybody who had a chance to join us
live or like who is watching this
recording if you could please let us
know what kind of other topics you might
be interested in in this sort of a free
webinar structure we have a little
survey uh down on the console
um and yeah I hope you all have a great
day a wonderful start of the of or like
end of the winter start of the spring
and yeah thank you everybody for joining
us yeah Petra this is wonderful we got
an astounding number of really great
questions it's too bad we're out of time
there's a lot to think about here and so
that's just another thank you to the
audience for all this food for thought
thank you